لان اليك الياس اذا انت في وسط المخيم
حدثنا عن تبعات ما حصل اليوم عن الاجواء
طبعا ولا شك انها اجواء جدا حزينه وغاضبه
حدثنا عنها
انتقلنا الى مكان اخر في مخيم جنين تحديدا
في هذا النادي الاجتماعي الذي لجا اليه
بعض المواطنين الفلسطينيين من المخيم مع
اجتياح قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي له صباح
هذا اليوم لكن قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
اقتحمت هذا المكان
بالجرافات وقوات الهندسه التي كانت معها
وعافت كل هذا الدمار في ممتلكات
الفلسطينيين وفي سياراتهم في عمليه انتقام
متكامله المعالم في احدى هذه السيارات حصر
احد المواطنين الفلسطينيين بعد ان قلبت
الجرافات الاسرائيليه همم السياره وهو في
داخلها مما تسبب له بجروح خطيره همم
للغايه هذه العمليه
الانتقاميه عمليه ترويع الفلسطينيين كانت
حاضره بقوه ليس فقط في استهداف المقاومين
المطلوبين لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي انما
ايضا
والفلسطينيين الامنين سواء كان ذلك في
منازلهم او داخل سياراتهم او في المنازل
الامنه التي خسرت ودمرت جراء هذه العمليه
العسكريه هنا في هذا النادي كما تشاهدون
اكثر من 10 سيارات دمرت وسحقت بالكامل
بعضها همم تم سحق هذه السيارات وال
السائقون الفلسطينيون في في داخلها همم
دون ان تكترث قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
لمنهم في داخل هذه السياره سواء كانوا
مقاومين همم او همم فلسطينيين امنين اللي
هي دخل لهم ولا صله لهم لا من قريب ولا من
بعيد في هذه العمليه حاله من الغضب الشديد
والحزن الشديد كذلك في المخيم نحن هنا في
النادي وقد بدا الفلسطينيين ايضا بالتوافق
همم الى هذا المكان لتقديم واجب العزاء
همم ذوي شهداء هذه المعركه همم في مخيم
جنين وهذه معركه بكل ما تحمله الكلمه من
معنى اا هذا ما يؤكده شهود العناء العيان
هذا ما تاكده الصور التي وصلت صباح هذا
اليوم من مخيم جنين حاله من الاشتباك بين
المقاومين والقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
على نحو غير مسبوق كما يقول الفلسطينيون
منذ الاشتياح الكبير المعروف للجميع في
عام
واثنين ايه كانت هنالك حضور للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه ولي بعض المسلحين الذين وصلوا
الى مكان الذي وجد فيه المطلوبين الثلاثه
لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي واشتركوا مع
جنود الاحتلال حتى ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بنفسه يقول بانه لم يتوقع هذا العدد
الكبير من المشتركين من المقاومين الذين
اشتركوا مع قواته المتوجهه في قلب مخيم
جنين وانه كان يرجع ان اعداد الشهداء
واعداد الجرحى ربما كانت ستكون اكبر همم
بكثير همم جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كما
اشرنا صلاته معلومات استخباراتيه دقيقه
تدل على مكان وجوده هؤلاء المطلوبين الذين
يقولوا بانه شاركوا في عمليات اطلاق نار
استهدفت دوريات الجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ولمستوطنات ربما قريبه من هذا المكان
تحديدا المستوطنه شاكيرا التي تعرضت في
ال- ايه اسابيع الماضيه الى اطلاق نار في
اكثر من مناسبه همم تم تطويق المنزل الذي
حصل في داخله المقاومين فيما يعرض باللغه
العسكريه
الضغط بمعنى تشكيل النيران كثيفه على
المنزل محاصرته عسكريه اطلاق ايضا صواريخ
الموجهه المضاده للدروع باتجاه المنزل
واحداث دمار هائل وكبير فيه وبعد ذلك
الاشتباك مع من جاء لاسناد المقاولين في
المخيم الطبيعه الحال هنالك حاله من
الادانه الشديده من كافه الفصائل همم
العمل الفلسطيني هم يقولون بان
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هذه المستمره في حق
الشعب الفلسطيني ما كانت لتحدث لولا الصمت
الدولي المطبق ازاء هذه الجمله
من داخل مخيم جنين حيث وقع الاقتحام اليوم
في ساعات الصباح